اكثر من 60 مليون ناخذ تركيا توجهون اليوم
الى مكتب التصويت في انتخابات او انتخابات
الرئاسيه برلمانيه
موضوع الحذر في غزه مع دخول الهدنه حيز
التنفيذ بعد خمسه ايام من القصف المتبادل
بعد مساعدات عسكريه المانيه ضخمه الرئيس
الاوكراني في برلين لاول مره منذ دراع
الحرب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره الاهم الانباء من
العربيه يتوجه اليوم اكثر من 60 مليون
ناخب تركي للابناء باصواتهم
وانتخاب رئيسهم الثالث عشر وكذلك اعضاء
البرلمان المؤلف من 600 مقعد رئيس المجلس
الاعلى للانتخابات اكد اتخاذ جميع
الاجراءات من اجل انتخابات صحيه وامنه
واصفا اليوم بمهرجان للديمقراطيه كما دعا
المواطنين المؤهلين للذهاب ولدي باصواتهم
مبدئيا اماله في اعلان النتائج غير
النهائيه اليوم
اخر ايام الحملات الانتخابيه في تركيا او
اخر ساعاتها ينشط انصار الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان في ميدان وسط انقره لاقناع
الناخبين بالتصويت لمرشحهم في انتخابات
الحسم كما يسمونها على الطرف الاخر من
الميدان انصار المعارضه لا ياللون جهدا في
شرح برامج مرشحهم للبرلمان والرئاسه
للماره الذين يصادفونهم في معسكر المعارضه
يبدون تفاؤلا حذرا مع اقرارهم بصعوبه
الانتخابات وتقارب فرص مرشحي الرئاسه
الابرز كمال كالجدار اوغلو ورجب طيب
اردوغان
بطن الزمن لا اعتقد بوجود فجوه كبيره في
المنافسه الانتخابيه اذ شن المرشحون حمله
كبيره تعتبر الاكثر تنافسيه بين كل مرشحي
الانتخابات الرئاسيه ما عدا سينانوجان
واذا رقبنا المنافسه الضخمه بين كليج دار
اوغلو واردوغان وتحدثنا عن حدودهما فاعتقد
ان الفارق بينهما سيكون ضئيلا جدا
على الجهه المقابله يقر داعم اردوغان
بصعوبه هذه الانتخابات وحساسيتها لكنهم
يعطون مرشحهم افضليه الفوز من الجوله
الاولى
[موسيقى]
الانتخابات حاسمه والمتوقع في الجوله
الاولى ان تكون النتيجه متقاربه لكونها
انتخابات رئاسيه لكن من وجهه نظري كباحث
سياسي اعتقد ان هناك احتمالا لفوز اردوغان
في الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات في الساعه
السادسه مساء ساد الصمت الانتخابي في عموم
تركيا شوارع انقره خلت من ممثلي الاحزاب
وسيارات الدعايه للمرشحين لا مزيد من
الحملات والترويج لاي كان فالوقت المتبقي
هو للناخب لاتخاذ قراره بعيدا عن زخم
الحملات الانتخابيه
افرغت الاحزاب السياسيه ما في جعبتها من
وعود انتخابيه وانهت حملات انتخابيه غير
مسبوقه لكثير من الاحزاب ويبقى القرار
النهائي للناخب حين يتوجه الى صناديق
الاقتراع زيدان زنجلو العربيه انقره
ساعه الحسم دقت في تركيا وعقاربها تشير
الى موعد التصويت في انتخابات هي الاصعب
والاهم في العقود الاخيره ربما استحقاقات
رئاسيه وبرلمانيه لكن الانظار كلها متجهه
نحو السباق الى كرسي الرئاسه اربعه
سيناريوهات محتمله لما بعد اغلاق مكاتب
الاقتراع الاول يتمثل في فوز الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان بفارق مريح وهنا قد يغلب
التصويت الايديولوجي لمصلحه حزب العداله
والتنميه المحافظ ما قد يشكل اعداما
سياسيا لمرشح المعارضه كما الكليتش دار
اوغلو السيناريو الثاني يتركز حول فوز
اردوغان بفارق ضئيل اي بخمسين بالمئه
زائدا واحد ما يفتح المجال لمواجهه قد
تنتقل من مكاتب الاقتراع الى قاعات القضاء
السيناريو الثالث عدم تحقيق اي من
المرشحين البارزين الفوز وبالتالي العوده
الى جوله ثانيه للحسم في اسم البلاد
المقبل اما السيناريو الرابع فهو فوز مرشح
المعارضه كمال كلتش دار اوغلو وانهاء فتره
قياده اردوغان لتركيا التي استمرت اكثر من
عشرين عاما هنا قد يكون الجانب الاقتصادي
مؤثرا في عمليات التصويت استطلاعات الراي
على مدار الايام الماضيه تعطي الفرصه
للطرفين للفوز مع افضليه لاردوغان ومع هذا
فان الانتخابات ستبقى مفتوحه على كل
الاحتمالات بلال البجدين العربيه
في ولايه هاتايا التركيه التي دمر زلزال
معظمها قبل ثلاثه اشهر يتحضر ناخبون ايضا
للتصويت لكن وسط تردد وحيره لمن يمنحون
اصواتهم هذه المره
انتقل احمد مع عائلته للسكن في مخيم
بالقرب من بيته المدمر في مدينه انطاكيا
املا بحصوله على تعويض عاجل بدلا من ان
يغادر المدينه يتحضر وسكان المخيم
للمشاركه في الانتخابات التركيه المقبله
في وقت تقوم الاحزاب السياسيه بحملات
انتخابيه خجوله وسط الدمار الذي ملا شوارع
المدينه
السياسه لم تعد تهمنا الحكومه ممكنه ان
تتغير لكن الوطن باقي بالتالي نحن الاتراك
وكل من يعيش في دولتنا يجب ان يكون همنا
المشترك حب الوطن والحفاظ عليه
من الركام الى صناديق الاقتراع في هاتاي
التي تسيطر عليها ايديولوجيات تاريخيه
وانتماءات حزبيه تدفع السكان للاصطفاف
السياسي مع الاحزاب المتنافسه على السلطه
زادت كارثه الزلزال
التلبث الاتراك
بخياراتهم وانتماءاتهم مله قردشتر الشاب
واخوه لكن السياسه فرقتنا فرحانيه وهذه
المنطقه يعطون اصواتهم لاردوغان لكن اذا
انتقلنا الى المنطقه الساحليه فاحبتنا
واقاربنا هناك يعطون اصواتهم للاحزاب
المعارضه يجب ان لا تفرق بين ان
الانتخابات اذهبوا الى الانتخابات واعطوا
صوتكم لمن تحبون
شهدتها تدميرا واسعا بفعل الزلزال الذي
جعل اكثر من 90% من منازلها ضمن قائمه
الهدم استمرت الاحزاب السياسيه بتراشق
الاتهامات على ان تنظم مدينه مدمره في وقت
ينتظر السكان لملمه الجراح وجبر الضرر
بالرغم ان الوالي والبلديات يتبعون
للحكومه فقدنا الكثير من الاشخاص تحت
الانقاض بسبب التقصير والتاخير والحكومه
تتظاهر بالحزن لخداعنا سينعكس ذلك على
الانتخابات بالتاكيد تشير توقعاته الى
استمرار سيطره المعارضه على النسبه الاعلى
في انتخابات هاتاي بينما يبدي الناخبون
مخاوفهم من عدم قدره الاحزاب السياسيه على
الايثاء بوعودهم خلال الفتره المقبله بسبب
حجم الدمار والخسائر الكبيره في المدينه
لا صوت هنا يعلو فوق صوت الموت والدمار
ترك الزلزال اثاره في كل شيء حتى اصوات
الناخبين المترددين المراقبين لاجراءات
الحكومه ما بعد الكارثه مسلم السيد عيسى
العربيه مدينه انطاكيا جنوبيه تركيا
دول رئيس اردوغان ينقسمون بين من سيصوت له
اقتراحا برؤيته وبينما سيقترعوا له لغياب
بديل مقنع مفرد العربيه زار احد الاحياء
التي تعد معقل لحزب العداله والتنميه في
اسطنبول الموفده عادت لنا بلا راي التاليه
الاقتصاديه في ظل حكمه شديده جدا كثير من
الناس لم يعودوا قادرين على تامين حاجتهم
وراتبنا بالكاد يكفي انا في حاله تردد من
ناحيه افكر ان اصوت لحزب الشعب الجمهوري
ومن ناحيه اخرى اقول ان حزب العداله
والتنميه انجز الكثير من الامور الايجابيه
خلال سنوات حكمه ربما الازمه الحاليه
مؤقته وستحل بعد الانتخابات رغم ما امر
فيه الا انني على الارجح ساصوت لحزب
العداله والتنميه بدافعي انه اكثر جداره
بالثقه لا اكثر
لانه يقدم لنا خدمات منذ 21 عاما في تركيا
هناك الكثير من الامور تغيرت خلال هذه
الفتره عمري 44 عاما لذلك شهدت مرحله ما
قبل اردوغان والواقع يشير الى تغيرات
مدهشه خلال فتره حكمه وتجلت انجازاته في
العديد من المنشات والمرافق مثل
المستشفيات والجسور والطرق وغيرها طرف
المعارضه يحتضر عناصر تسعى لتقسيم تركيا
لذلك لابد من تاييد الرئيس اردوغان يعني
الذهاب الى المدرسه والجامعه كمحجبه اما
في عهده نلت الحريه لا ارى بديلا له من
ناحيه القوه والزعامه ورد الحقوق للشعب
التركي بكافه طبقاته وفئته
وفضل المتحدث باسم
اتهامات المعارضه التركيه بالتدخل في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه وشكك بسكوب في قدره
زعيم المعارضه كمال على تقديم دليل على
تدخل الروسيه المزعوم وضيف لنا موسكو
ستحترم خيار شعب التركي في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله
حاله من الهدوء الحاضر تسود قطاع غزه
واسرائيل على الرغم من تسجيل قصف متبادل
محدود من الجانبين في بدايه التي دخلت حيز
التنفيذ قبل ساعات ببساطه مصريه قد اعلن
البيت الابيض ان الولايات المتحده ترحب
بوقف اطلاق النار في غزه وتشيد بالدور
المصري بهذا السطر
مصادر العربيه ان لجنه مصريه تقوم
بالاشراف على وقف اطلاق النار في غزه شهرت
المصادر الى انه سيتم ادخال وقود الى
القطاع
ومساعدات انسانيه خلال ساعات المقبله وان
الامر متوقف على مدى الالتزام بوقف اطلاق
النار اضيفه انه تم بدء مفاوضات لهدنه
طويله الامد تتضمن بنودا ملزمه لكلا
الطرفين وفق المصادر نفسها تجرى ترتيبات
لزياره مسؤولي حركه الجهاد لمصر خلال
الساعات المقبله
اعلن المتحدث الرسمي باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني انه تم استدعاء
السفير العراقي لوزاره الخارجيه بسبب دعوه
عظام من وصفهم بجماعات انفصاليه لحضور حفل
رسمي في كردستان العراق كنعاني قال انه تم
ابلاغ سفير العراقي احتجاج طهران الشديد
على دعوه اعضاء جماعات انفصاليه واستمرار
بعض انشطه تلك الجماعات في منطقه كردستان
العراق واصفا هذا الاجراء بانه يتعارض مع
الاتفاق الامني الاخير بين طهران وبغداد
مددت سوريا الاذنه للامم المتحده
ووكالاتها باستخدام معبري باب السلامه
والراعي لثلاثه اشهر اضافيه لتسهيل وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه الى جميع المحتاجين
والمتضررين ونقلت وسائل الاعلام السوريه
عن مندوب سوريا الدائم لدى الامم المتحده
قوله ان القرار ياتي انطلاقا من حرص سوريا
على تعزيز الاستقرار وتحسين الوضع المعيشي
والانساني لكل السوريين ومتضررين الزلزال
تتابعون ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد قليل
رسول سابق في بايد دانس المالكه لتيك توك
يتهم شركه بمنح بكين امكانيه الدخول الى
بيانات الامريكيين
اهلا بكم مجددا الى هذه النشره افادت
صحيفه كما سانتا روسيه باسقاط مقاتلتين
روسيتين من طراز سوخوي 34
وسوخوي 35 اضافه الى طائرتين هليكوبتر امس
في منطقه الروسيه المتاخمه لاوكرانيا
وفيما سيكون ذلك ضربه قويه من جانب كيف
اذا تاكدت مسؤوليه عن ذلك
ولم يصطلح حتى الان اي رد فعل الرسمي من
جانب كيف التي عاده ما ترفض التعليق على
اي هجمات داخل روسيا
بعد ايطاليا وصل الرئيس الاوكراني الى
برلين وذلك في اول زياره رسميه له الى
العاصمه الالمانيه منذ العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه الخاصه في اوكرانيا وقال انه
سيبحث خلال زيارته موضوعات اعاده الاعمار
وتقديم المزيد من الاسلحه اضافه الى مساله
انضمام الى عضويه النيتو وكانت وزاره
الدفاع الالمانيه قد اعلنت مؤخرا انها تعد
مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه
تناهز ثلاثه مليارات دولار بما في ذلك
الدبابات والانظمه المضاده للطائرات
قال الرسول سياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيفوريل ان اوكرانيا تحتاج الى
نحو الف قذيفه مدفعيه يوميا في منطقه
بخموت وحدها في اشاره لحده القتال مع
روسيا هناك وحاجه اوكرانيا للدعم العسكري
وفق بيان للاتحاد الاوروبي اضاف بوريل انه
التقى وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني دي مترو
كوليبا والذي اطبعه على التطورات في
اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان القتال يستمر في
منطقه بخموت وضروره الاسراع بتوفير
الذخيره لهذه المعركه
في هذه الاثناء اكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انها تتقدم داخل باخموت وسيطرت على حي في
القسم الشمالي الغربي من المدينه ذات
الامر اكده الجانب المقابل قائد سلاح البر
الاوكراني شدد على ان القوات الاوكرانيه
احرز التقدما باتجاه بعض المناطق الواقعه
بالقرب من خط المواجهه في ضخموت شرقي
البلاد
معنويات الاوكرانيين كما سماها حتى اللحظه
فروسيا اقرت بتراجع قواتها للوراء شماليه
مدينه باخموت اثر هجوم اوكرانيا جديد
انسحاب وصفه رئيس مجموعه فاجنر بالهزيمه
النكراء بل اتهم الجيش الروسي بالفرار من
مواقعه
هذا التطور قطره من سيل هجمات لفظيه يواصل
على القياده الروسيه لتطرح تساؤلات عن سر
تحمل الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين وقائد
الثاني اقوى جيوش العالم لاهانات رئيس
مرتزقه ليس اكثر
معركه باخموت كانت الاكثر ابرازا لقوات
فاغنر غير ان ركود غضب بوتين تجاه تطاول
بريكوجين عليه لا يتوقف عند الدفع بقواته
ذات السمعه السيئه للجبهات الاماميه او
التضحيه بهم بل يرتبط بمجموعه حجج تعود
لحقبه ستالين وفق موقع موقع فورنفرز
حاجه الرئيس الروسي الى قوات شبه عسكريه
تعود اولا لكبح جمح الجيش الذي طالما
اعتبره تهديدا محتملا لحكمه فالجيوش تميل
بزمن الحروب الى اكتساب المزيد من القوه
داخل الدوله لدرجه يصعب احتوائها او
التحكم بها احيانا الاعتماد على فاجنر ليس
الا احدث تطور في تاريخ طويل من الاعتماد
الروسي والسوفيتي على قوات غير نظاميه
تقليد قديم يعود الى الحقبه السوفيتيه
عندما استخدم الكريم قوات بالوكاله للتدخل
في نزاعات حول العالم احدها الحرب الاهليه
الاسبانيه في ثلاثينات القرن الماضي بحجه
محاربه الفاشيه او ما عد لاحقا المقدمه
المباشره لمعركه روسيا الضخمه ضد النازيه
في الحرب العالميه الثانيه تبرير استخدمه
الكريم مجددا في اوكرانيا
ليبقى العامل الاكثر اهميه في دور فاغنر
المستمر هو بوتين نفسه فابريجين لم يدخل
دائره التهديدات السياسيه المحيطه به ولا
يزال مفيدا حتى اللحظه
صوت مليون ونحو 800 موريتاني لاختيار
برلماني جديد ومجالس جمهوريه وبلديه في
انتخابات تشهد تنافسا حادا خصوصا في
العاصمه وكبريات المدن بين 25 حزبا
اقبال الكبير على مراكز الاختراع في
الانتخابات الثلاثيه البرلمانيه والجهويه
والبلديه يؤشر الاحتمال تسجيل نسبه مشاركه
مرتفعه ورغم حده المنافسه خصوصا في
العاصمه وكبريات مدن البلاد فقد طبع
الهدوء واجواء المراكز الانتخابيه
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله صوتك كامل تبارك
الله
واجواء تنافسيه زينه وروح رياضيه
ومحترمه وبالهدوء وبالنظام الحمد لله
الساعه
الوحده
يصوتون في هذا الاقتراع على ست قوائم ثلاث
منها وطنيه اضافه الى لائحه الدائره
البرلمانيه المحليه والقائمتين البلديه
والجهويه ما يعقد نسبيا عمليه التصويت
براي المراكبين وقد يستدعي تمديد وقت
التصويت
الاقبال كثيف واعلن المكاتب مسجل فيها قدر
من الخلق وفم في سير العمليه الانتخابيه
مما يسالنا عندنا تخوف اعلن العمليه
الانتخابيه
ما يكتمل كل مكتب قد ما يكمل عدد
عدد الناخبين نحن نقول الامور كامله
الجهات المعنيه
وتدخل تتدخل اللجنه بنفس الوقت وتدخل جهه
اي ملاحظه
اللجنه جاهزه
لجميع المشاكل
يتنافسوا في الانتخابات الجاريه 25 حزبا
على مقاعد البرلمان البالغه 176
تعتمد النسبيه لانتخاب نصفها و13 مجلسا
جهويا ونحو 240 بلديه
تكتسي الانتخابات الحاليه اهميه خاصه فهي
تنظم على مشارف انتخابات رئاسيه مقرره
للعام القادم يرجح ان يترشح فيها الرئيس
الحالي لعهده ثانيه وهو ما يفسر حده معركه
تعزيز المواقع بين اطراف العمليات
السياسيه ابراهيم مصطفى العربيه نواكشوط
رجحت جبهه الخلاص المعارضه في تونس ان
تشهد البلاد خلال الايام القادمه حمله
اعتقالات جديده على خلفيه دعوه الرئيس قيس
سعيد لتطهير الاداره العامه ممن وصفهم
بالمندسين وفي تصريحات اعلاميه قال رئيس
الجبهه التي تقودها النهضه نجيب الشابي ان
طلب سعيد من الوزراء تطهير الاداره هو
اذان بان حمله الاعتقالات ستتوسع وكان
صعيد قداكد سابقا على ضروره تطهير الاداره
التونسيه من كل من اندس داخلها ويعمل على
تعطيل السير العادي لها مشددا على ان
الوزارات المنشاه العامه لا يمكن ان تقوم
بوظيفتها في وجود من يعمل داخلها لقاده
جهه معينه
حلقه جديده من الجدل الذي يثيره تطبيق تيك
توك في الولايات المتحده حيث رفع مسؤول
تنفيذي كبير سابق بالشركه
دعاوى على الشركه ما ينذر بخطر وشيك قد
يهدد وجوده
حلقه جديده يشهدها مسلسل التطبيق الاكثر
جدلا في الولايات المتحده تيك توك مدير
تنفيذي سابق للشركه
يرفع دعوى قضائيه بعد عده سنوات من فشل
الوصول الى تسويه مع الشركه
الفصل غير المشروع كان الشكوى الاولى التي
قدمها
والتي اتخذتها الشركه بسبب كشف يو لمخطط
عالمي لسرقه الملكيه الفكريه لشركات اخرى
والربح منها
من بين الادعاءات الاكثر لفتا للانتباه في
دعوه ان مكاتب باي دانس في بكين لديها
وحده خاصه من اعضاء الحزب الشيوعي الصيني
يشار اليها باسم اللجنه مهمتها مراقبه
التطبيقات الشركه وارشاد الشركه لتطبيق
القيم الشيوعيه الاساسيه وامتلاك مفتاح
الموت الذي قد يؤدي الى ايقاف تشغيل
التطبيقات الصينيه
ولعل اكثر ما اكد شكوك الامريكيه حول
التطبيق ادعاء السيد يوم ابقاء اللجنه ضمن
دائره الوصول الفائق الى جميع بيانات
الشركه حتى البيانات المخزنه في الولايات
المتحده
تظهر ادعاءات السيد يو كذلك ان مهندسي
شركه نسخوا مقاطع فيديو ومنشورات من
تطبيقات وانستجرام ثم نشروها دون اذن
والهدف كما يدعي السيد ديو خلقه جيش من
الروبوتات لتعزيز ارقام المشاركه ورفع
قيمتها السوقيه باسرع وقت ممكن
خلال الاشهر التي عمل فيها سيد يوب من عام
2017 الى 2018 شهد على تعديل الخوارزميات
لرفع محتوى يعبر عن كراهيه اليابان بجعل
المنشورات اكثر بروزا للمستخدمين يبدو ان
الفوضى داخل الشركه بدات تتسرب فبعد ان
طالت المؤسس تهم برشوه مسؤول كبير مكلف
بتنظيم الانترنت في الصين في 2018
ها هي الشركه تتلقى ضربه موجعه وتتهم
بالخروج عن القانون في دوله يستخدم
تطبيقها اكثر من 150 مليون امريكي كرم
حناوي العربيه
في الختام تذكير بالعناوين
اكثر من 60 مليون ناخب تركيا توجهون اليوم
الى مكاتب التصويت في انتخابات رئاسيه
وبرلمانيه
هدوء حظر في غزه مع دخول الهدنه حيز
التنفيذ بعد خمسه ايام من القصف المتبادل
بعد مساعدات عسكريه المانيه ضخمه الرئيس
الاوكراني في برلين لاول مره منذ اندلاع
الحرب
شكرا لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات